hey this is press to
Walker here's a delightful problem start
with triangle
ABC construct a d where D is on the side
BC then construct be where e is on the
side
AC finally construct
CF where f is on the side AB and all
three segments a d b and CF intersect at
a mutual Point G this divides the
triangle into six smaller
triangles we know the areas of four of
these smaller
triangles C EG is equal to
84 bdg is equal to 35 BFG is equal to 30
and afg is equal to
40 assuming such a triangle construction
exists what is the area of triangle
ABC pause the video if you'd like to
give this problem problem a try and when
you're ready keep watching to learn how
to solve this
problem in order to solve the problem
let's review the formula for the area of
a triangle suppose we have a right
triangle with a base b and a height H
the area of the triangle is equal to2 *
B *
H but this formula is true not just for
right triangle
so long as the height H is an altitude
upon the base B from the opposite vertex
the same formula is true the area of the
triangle is equal to 12 * B *
H so all triangles that have the same
base and the same length of the height
will have the same area this is true
even if the height is outside of the
triangle so area is equal to 1/2 * B *
H now it's such a useful formula and we
take it for granted and it made me think
I never learned where this formula came
from in any of my textbooks in school I
didn't learn it in any of the books that
I read at the library because I loved
math and I read every single bestseller
whether it was the New York Times
bestseller or
otherwise and I never learned it through
my Stanford math education or even in
any other videos so I wondered where
exactly did this formula come from that
we take for
granted so thankfully we now have
Wikipedia to fill in the Gap I looked up
the entry for area of a triangle and you
can scroll down to the section where it
says history so it starts out with
Heron's formula and then we get to the
part about uclid in 300 BCE Greek
mathematician uid proved that the area
of a triangle is half that of a
parallelogram with the same base and
height in his book's elements of
geometry in 499 Arya but a great
mathematician astronomer from the
classical age of Indian mathematics and
Indian astronomy Express the area of a
triangle as 1/2 the base times the
height in the Arya buta section 2.6 so
it actually looks to me that it comes
from ARA butut so uclid did prove it's
equal to half that of a parallelogram
but it doesn't actually say what the
formula for the parallel is so it's
quite interesting to learn a bit of
history that I had never learned before
for such an amazing formula that we just
take for granted the area of a triangle
is equal to/ 12 * the base time the
height so how's that going to help us
solve this
problem so first of all we have triangle
AEG G let's say it has an area equal to
X then we have triangle CG D and let's
say that is an area equal to Y we know
the areas of some of these triangles so
let's Express the formula for the areas
in terms of the base and the height now
look at triangle
afg the base will be AF and we will
construct the height from G upon the
base AF and let's say this has a length
equal to H so the area of this triangle
is equal to 40 so we have 40 is equal to
12 time the base AF time the height h
but now let's do the same thing for the
triangle
BFG the important part is that it will
be the same height H the base is going
to be BF and the area is equal to 30 so
we have 30 is equal to 12 * BF *
H we can now take the ratio of these two
equations we have 40 over 30 is equal
to2 * 8 a f * H this is all over 12 * BF
* H now an amazing thing happens the H
terms cancel and the 1/2 factors cancel
so we have 40 over 30 is equal to AF /
by
BF so let's just take this and move it
to the side for a
second we will do another calculation
just like this let's consider another
triangle with the base a
let's consider triangle
ACF now let's construct the height from
the vertex C to the base AF let's say
this has height Capital H so what's the
area of this triangle it will be the sum
of the three areas 40 x and
84 so this will be 124 + x is the area
and that's also equal to 12 * the base a
AF time Capital H the
height now let's do the same thing for
triangle
BCF we have a different base BF but we
have the same height Capital H so the
area of this triangle is the sum of the
areas of these three triangles so we
have 30 + 35 + y and that works out to
be 65 + y this is equal to 12 * the base
F time the height Capital
H once again we'll take the ratio of
these two equations so we have 124 + x /
65 + y is equal to 12 * AF * Capital H
all over 12 * BF * Capital
H the 1/ 12 Capital H factors will
cancel so we have 124 + x / 65 + y is
equal to a over
BF so now let's take a look at these
equations we have two equations that are
both equal to AF over BF therefore
they're equal to each other so 124 + x /
65 + y is equal to 40 over
30 we can cross
multiply now let's divide both sides of
this equation by 10 and then distribute
this results in the equation 372 + 3x is
equal to 260 + 4 y we will simplify this
to 112 + 3x is equal to 4
y so we made some progress but we're
still not there we still need to figure
out what the values of X and Y are so we
need another
equation so we'll put this equation to
the side and now let's take another side
of the triangle and try the same sort of
thing so let's look at side
BC consider the triangle bdg it has an
area of 35 we could construct the height
from G to the base BD so we would get
something we would also do the same
thing for the triangle CDG we know its
area is equal to Y we construct the same
height from G to the base CD and we know
that its area 12 * CD * the height so we
can take the ratio of areas of these two
triangles and we know that 35 over Y is
equal to the ratio of the bases of these
triangles BD Over
CD let's do the same thing for this
triangle BDA and this triangle
CDA the ratio of the areas of these two
triangles will be equal to the ratio of
the
bases so we have 105 which is equal to
40 + 30 +
35 this is divided by the area 84 + x +
y and that's equal to the same ratio BD
divided by
CD so both of these equations are equal
to BD Over CD so we can just look at
these equations being equal to each
other we now cross multiply and then we
can simplify by dividing both sides by
35 so if 84 + x + y is equal to 3 Y
which means 84 + x is equal to 2
y so now we have two equations for X and
Y so we'll solve for x and y we'll
multiply the second equation by two
giving 168 + 2x is equal to 4 y the
first and third equations are equal to 4
y so they must be equal to each other
so 168 + 2x is = 112 + 3x simplifying
gives that X is equal to
56 we can then substitute this into the
second equation and we get 84 + 56 is
equal to 2 Y and simplifying will give
that Y is equal to
70 so we just need to substitute these
values in the area of triangle ABC is
equal to x + 84 + y + 35 + 30 + 40 we
substitute in and then simplify and that
gives us the area of ABC is equal to
3155 and that's the
answer thanks for making us one of the
best communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a
time
[Music]
w